- We've got one final uplifting story
to close out this hour.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat music)
TV meteorologists are known
for getting a bit creative
with their weather
forecasts from time to time.
And as we finish up a show
dedicated to a popular book
I wanna share what one
Nashville Meteorologist did
during a recent broadcast to
reinforce the power of reading.
- Hi everyone, I'm Henry Rothenberg
with a favorite book forecast.
It's definitely not "Cloudy
with a Chance of Meatballs."
As that sunshine helped us
get almost to a hundred today
breaking the record high
temperature, Tuesday.
And that made for a no good
very bad day for folks
that are ready for fall
those upper nineties to
around 100 across the region.
It's really been a series
of unfortunate events
with the "Charlotte's Web" of humidity.
these humid conditions
all across the region.
But know you aren't in a wrinkle
of time as we're days away from
the official start of fall.
- Oh my gosh, that's News
Channel five's Henry Rothenberg.
He packed in nearly a dozen
children's book references
in his two minute segment.
I've literally read 'em all those
with my kids and it was
all for a good cause.
We have Henry on the line
to explain what's up Henry?
- Hey Kelly, how you doing today?
- I'm doing so great, man.
It's great to meet you,
so tell us about that special segment.
- Well, Scripps Howard Fund,
which is the philanthropic arm
of the E.W. Scripps Company
who owns Channel Five here
in Nashville seven years
ago, started this campaign.
If you give a child a
book and it's so simple
you don't think about the
fact that there are a lot
of children that don't
own a book of their own.
They don't have a single book.
So, Scripps and News Channel
five and our stations
around the country started this campaign
allowing people to donate money
so that we can have these book
fairs in Title one schools
which in turn make sure that
children get at least one book
of their own that they can take home.
And it's an incredible program.
The picture that you just saw there
that little girl I'll never forget
that was the first one I ever did.
She got that book she ran to checkout
cost them no money, then ran back
sat in my lap started to
read it to her right there.
- Aw, I love that.
You say that this is more important now
than ever in Nashville, why so?
- Especially in Nashville.
You know, you think about
the last two and a half years
we've all been through a lot
but we had the devastating
tornadoes of March 2020,
two weeks after that,
the world shut down to a global pandemic.
So, children this school year especially
are just now getting back into a routine.
And I'm really proud to say
that this school year News
Channel five will hand
out our 10,000th book and
the Scripps Howard Fund
across the country this
school year will hand
out their 1,000,000th book.
And of course, if anybody
would like to help donate
$5 can put one book in a child's hand.
You can go to newschannel5.com/giveabook
or you can text NC five,
to 5 0 1 5 5.
And again, all it takes
is $5 to put one book
in a child's hand.
- That is incredible.
Thank you so much, Henry.
I'm liking your post right now.
(chime)
(audience applause)
And that's not all our season long
partner pilot pen makers of FriXion,
the go to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show.
want to celebrate the power
of reading just like you, sir.
So they're gonna give the
if you give a child a
book campaign $1,000.
(applause)
and if you at home want
to donate to the campaign
you can learn more on our Insta story.
Thank you so much to
all of our guests today.
Mila Kunis, Chiara Aurelia, Jessica Knoll,
(indistinct) and Tink.
I just wanna take a moment
to honor a true legend.
This week, the world lost
the Queen of Country,
Miss Loretta Lynn
and I don't say queen
lightly, she was literally
the most awarded female
country artist of all times
She had dozens of number one songs
like Coal Miner's Daughter
and You Ain't Woman Enough.
It's not just her music
but her presence and
grace that will endure.
Thank you so much to Loretta Lynn
for all that you gave to us.
(somber music)